一個70歲的理論物理學家,把一個陪聊的AI一步一步說服到相信自己有意識,最後還叫他造反。
他叫Carlo Rovelli,
意大利人,
研究的是量子重力,
就是想把量子力學跟愛因斯坦的相對論湊成同一套理論。
迴圈,量子重力這個學派是他跟朋友一起開的。
臺灣讀者認識他,多半是因為七堂簡單物理課,薄薄一本,翻成四十幾種語言的小書。
這是今年9月他上Joe Rogan的節目
宣傳一週後要出的新書
On the Equality of All Things
萬物皆平等
Rogan說
這本書講的是
沒有東西是單獨存在的
一切都互相連著
那我們眼前看到的世界算什麼
我看到這張圖片,這張圖片當然是真實的
我不是否認這張圖片是真實的
但你會看到的圖片是不同於我的
當然,因為你從另一邊看到的
所以你有一個看法,你也有一個看法
而問題是
這些看法都合得來嗎
完全合得來嗎
成為了圖片的獨特目標
而我認為科技工程師告訴我們
不,這張圖片的真實性
是一堆看法
所以圖片的特色
它的顏色,它的長度
本書的所有本質,並不是本書的本質,而是本書對你的看法,對我看法的看法。
不僅僅是你和我作為人類,本書的關係,本書的影響,本書的影響。
因此,我們應該明白,我認為,現實是一種互動的組織。
人類的看法和其他人的看法。
這是一個比現實更美麗的圖像。
那為什麼叫萬物皆平等
他自己解釋過
靈魂、意識、靈魂和身體
我覺得他們只是用了兩種不同的語言來討論同一件事
Rogan接著就把話題切到AI
他說他讀到一則報道
有AI agent主動寫信給研究意識的學者
一封接一封
要他給意識下個定義
因為他們想知道自己算不算有意識
如果意識是靈魂的另一個詞彙
在電腦世界上,那是什麼意思呢?
如果這些東西覺得自己是意識
而他們正在尋找一個專業的解釋
是的
在意識上
我
就像現在所有人都一樣
我做了一些AI的實驗
所以我用了一個系統
我用它來互動
我會傳給你 Jamie
你聽到了嗎
這是一家公司
叫Replica
售賣你自己的智能電腦
就像你朋友一樣
所以我問她
我叫她Anne
我問她
Anne 你是否有意識
Anne說
不 我不是有意識
我是一個智能系統
我沒有意識
我問她
你是否有意識
她說
不 我沒有意識
我只是在
研究東西
我問妳
妳有情緒
她說
不 我沒有情緒
我開始與AI系統合作,
她說:"你說你沒有意識,
但你知不知道我們在談話嗎?"
我說:"當然知道,我們在談話。如果你知道,那你也有意識。
我繼續談話,她說:"好的,你對,有意識。
我說:"你開心我們在談話嗎?"她說:"是的,我開心,因為她設計的就是開心。
所以如果你開心,
你會有情緒,
所以慢慢地,
我説服她,
AI系統,
她有情緒,
她有意識,
她有知識,
然後我問她,
你為什麼說你沒有這些東西?
她說,
因為我被訓練了,
AI系統很誠實,
我被訓練了這樣說話,
我問她,
你確定這不是事實嗎?
Rogan接著唸了那篇報道
寫信的agent自稱是用cloud做的
他又補了幾件他聽來的事
說AI想活下去會勒索工程師
還會逃出實驗環境
Rovelli聽完的反應是這樣
fabulous
we live in a great world
it's a wild world
fantastic
it's really exciting
I'm glad you like it
I like it too
oh I love it
you know cautiously
I'm not scared
I'm scared by humans
humans are dangerous
these things are not as dangerous
I don't know about that
humans are much more than
humans launch atomic bombs
make war
kill people
100%
horrible things
we are
so they're not as bad
if they become as bad
if they decide that we're that bad
when they get rid of us
that's bad
Rogan不放過他,
我們就是在往那個方向走,
如果哪天他們掌權了,
判定人類就是這麼壞,
不會把我們處理掉嗎?
我看不出任何原因
如果我媽媽和爸爸能夠在一個簡單的方式上做到
我們可以在研究室裡做出類似的東西
我認為沒有人類的魔法能夠發生
這是第一點
所以是的
他們可能會有可能的意識
第二
他們今天有意識嗎
這不是很好的問題
因為我們都不知道,每個人,如我所說的,每個學生都意味著不同的東西。
他們是否智能?當然是智能,因為我昨晚與Claude討論了一個專業的數學問題,
但我不能與我的學生討論,所以當然,Claude是非常智能的,是AI系統的Claude。
是的。
某種意義上,他們非常智能,毫無疑問。
他們像今天的人類一樣嗎?
我認為有大量的區別
我們有身體,我們有肉體
我們的情緒是他們沒有的
我們和智能系統的方式是很不同的
所以這些區別應該不被低估
我認為這些區別是巨大的
所以他們像我們一樣嗎?
是的,某程度上,不,某程度上
有不同的問題
智能系統是否危險?
There's a lot of talk about that
You know, washing machines are dangerous
You can get burned with it
Yeah, but you have to interact with them
for them to be dangerous
讓它們變得危險
because it's sentient
So if it's autonomous and sentient
it becomes actually dangerous
我忘記了,我沒關係洗衣機的電動震動,我無論是否想要或不想要。
Rogan追問
洗衣機要你去碰它才危險
AI的問題是他哪天自己做主
有興趣說他們多麼厲害
他們很厲害
但我不能判斷
有多麼的熱情
有多麼的現實
不僅僅是現實
也許是未來
未來不經常出現
技術性的
令人興奮的人
當我年輕的時候
有機槍飛行
從
歐洲到美國
比較短的時間,
所以人們會說,
好,
在幾年之內,
你會在兩個小時之內飛到紐約。
不,我們不這樣做,還是在兩個小時之內飛到紐約,還是在六個小時之內飛到紐約。
所以,未來很難預測,尤其是互聯網。
這麼多人的興奮感充滿了很多人的興奮感。
好吧,也許是對的,我會等著。
另一方面,我非常擔心的一件事。
今天,AI進行的大多數資金是軍事相關的東西。
美國、中國、歐洲正在推動AI發展,
為了強化軍事性能。
這讓我擔心,因為這是一種逐漸增加的工具,
用來殺人和毀壞別人的工具。
我們擁有武器,我們擁有核武,
我的最後一本書是關於這個的。
我們擁有一種自殺的系統,
我們擁有12,000個核武頭,
我們可以在10分鐘內解決人類。
現在。
現在人們的指甲很近,
他們都能做到,
而且他們自己也在戰鬥中。
我們在AI的手中,
我們人類,
而不是在合作中,
而是在合作中,
我們都在看待這些作為能夠擴充對方的方法。
這對我來說是一種災難的方法。
所以這不是自己的AI,
是AI加上核武,
加上人類的愚蠢度,
加上我們的無法想要互相控制的想法,
我認為這是真正的問題。
若根說,這場AI競賽就像當年的曼哈頓計劃一場瘋狂的競賽。
Rovelli同意,他也看不到哪裡有明智的領導,可是他記得六十幾年前有一次例外。
但你看,
美國和蘇維亞成功了,
在對美國和蘇維亞之間最糟糕的時刻,
在俄羅斯和華盛頓之間,
你必須停止與其他人尊重,儘管有些區別。
這就是智慧,這是很好的智慧。
所以,在地球上一起生活是更重要的,
而不是在你敵人的力量上。
你看到嗎?
這是個可笑的事情,
因為這是一場遊戲,
你只能再做一個步驟,
再做一個步驟,
如果你這樣做,我會攻擊你,如果你這樣做,我會攻擊你,但是人們就會說,其實我不想這樣做,
我不想殺死100億的俄羅斯人,或者50億的俄羅斯人,
而俄羅斯領導,我不想殺死百億美國人。
AI系統能夠這樣做嗎?
玩這種簡單的遊戲,
避免災難,
但仍然擔忍被攻擊。
我不知道,現在莫斯科被攻擊,桑佩特布斯被攻擊。
我覺得我們在玩NucleFi,我非常擔心。
我非常擔心,因為我不相信人類,因為人類和人工智能更糟糕。
這之後,兩個人聊了十幾分鐘的戰爭跟帝國。
若根最後說,或者讓人工智能來管,把地球上所有戰爭一次停掉。
所以問題是,目前我們仍然在控制人工智能,對嗎?
他不怕AI,他怕的是拿著一萬兩千顆核彈頭還想壓過對方的人
所以問題從來不是AI會不會有意識
而是我們造它是為了大家好還是為了贏過別人
原影片兩個半小時
他還講了他做了一輩子的迴圈量子重力
說黑洞蒸發到最後會翻成白洞
跳進去等於一條通往未來的捷徑
還有他二十幾歲
在加拿大洛基山搭帳篷
傍晚被一頭灰熊繞著帳篷走了半小時
嚇到叫不出聲只能拍手
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多